oh my god ned he's my best friend oh my
aunt may should really stop talking
what just
happened welcome to your weekly ticket
spider-man no way home has become one of
fandango's biggest pre-sellers of all
time with the most advanced tickets sold
since avengers end game the spider-man
film is tracking to become the first
movie to open to more than 100 million
dollars since star wars the rise of
skywalker opened to 177 million
domestically in december 2019. during
the holiday break we'll also get the
matrix resurrections and the kingsman
for the action and adventure crowd a
journal for jordan an american underdog
for the tearjerker audience and the
family sing-along options of sing 2 and
west side story
the script said for me to go listen to
the melody but i already saw the play
i'm cultured okay phantom of the opera
was universal's first horror movie and
it's now getting a modern musical update
courtesy of screenwriter john fusco
singer-songwriter and e-got recipient
john legend will produce phantom
alongside mike jackson and harvey mason
jr the new orleans set phantom news
follows a flurry of recent updates on
remakes of the classic universal monster
movies in the past few weeks we've
learned that blue valentine director
derek c in france will re-team with ryan
gosling for the wolf man and that
nicholas cage will play dracula opposite
aquafina and nicholas holt in reinfeld
this
actually won't be cage's first turn as a
vampire however
meanwhile christopher nolan continues to
add just the biggest stars possible to
his next film florence pew and romney
malek are joining killian murphy emily
blunt matt damon and robert downey jr in
oppenheimer as we mentioned in a
previous episode murphy will play j
robert oppenheimer the inventor of the
atomic bomb blunt will play his wife pew
will play a member of the communist
party whose affair with oppenheimer
causes security concerns malik will play
a scientist damon the director of the
manhattan project and downey jr will
play the infamous chairman of the atomic
energy commission who question
oppenheimer's loyalty to the united
states the star-studded cast will grace
the silver screen july 2023 and when
you're the top grossing movie of the
year of course you're gonna get a sequel
destin daniel [ __ ] is returning to
write and direct the next xiangchi film
the sequel was officially announced as
part of a development deal that [ __ ]
signed with disney which included a new
adventure with simulator chongqi [ __ ]
told collider it's a fun place to be
right now everything is a possibility
we're just tossing very loose sequel
ideas around and we'll start to hone in
on something soon hopefully
xiang chi was also chosen by fandango
users as their favorite film of 2021 in
a fan pick survey more on that later but
now to the most anticipated movie of the
year
the wait is finally over spider-man no
way home the culmination of the first
tom holland spider-man trilogy is in
theaters this friday in the film peter
parker asks doctor strange to do a spell
that will make the world forget he is
spider-man but the spell has
consequences it opens up the multiverse
and spits out villains from previous
spider-man films including alfred
molina's doc ock jamie foxx's electro
and willem dafoe's green goblin we
recently had the no way home cast of
holland zendaya and jacob batlon ask
each other questions about their
characters past present and future name
your top three spider-man villains
you've had to square off against and who
do you want to see him take on next oh
that's tricky
i think the vulture's got to be in there
because he's my first
that one's cool i think jake's got to be
in there because he's my love
he's jake
and i think willem
the fight scenes that we have with
william in this film almost so crazy and
so scary that it really was
awesome to like explore different kind
of spider-man action who do you want to
see him take on this though do you know
what i actually think that morbius film
looks really cool
and it's quite scary that film yeah it
does look scary i think morbius could be
quite a cool thing too yeah to mix that
up spider-man versus a vampire
[Laughter]
both the spider-man movies and euphoria
are in high school settings what advice
do you think roo and mj would give each
other i don't know if roo should be
given any advice right now
i think maybe she should just
chill you know
um excuse some advice maybe maybe ask
her in a few years you know nice she'll
have great advice then
but um i would say
i don't know i don't know if they would
give each other advice so much it's just
i i think they'd actually really get
along i think they would i think they
would be good for each other i think mj
would be excellent for rude yeah
if ned got a spin-off what do you think
it would look like pitch us your show oh
yeah please spin off so a ned lead
spin-off would probably be
uh one where he
works with
the avengers shield shield yes yes
so right like an official guy in the
chair so he would be sick and i feel
like he'd probably work with every
superhero
not just spiderman and leave me i mean i
would i would give you all my time and
also other people my time nice and i
feel like give me all of your time if
you're giving other people time a tv
show with you and
fury yeah really funny i think that'll
be hilarious it's like his new little uh
protege yeah shadowing him they'll be
holding it like just the fury of a
notepad like why did you make that
decision
yeah because the other one is a spoiler
yeah oh ha
interesting his other possible plot
things to come
in theaters on friday is spider-man no
way home and nightmare alley
microphones that's right
fire recorder
you recording this
no
my office is wired to record all
analysis sessions
you got a smoother line but you run a
rack same as me
set against the backdrop of carnival
entertainment in america pre-world war
ii nightmare alley shows a man with a
shadowy past rise from the bottom of the
world to the top of society through
tricks he learned in the big ten
with a talent for manipulating people
using only a few chosen words he hooks
up with a female psychiatrist who is
even more dangerous than he is bradley
cooper plays the former kearney and cate
blanchett plays the psychiatrist and
guillermo del toro's film noir nightmare
alley is a more faithful update of a
1946 novel that was previously turned
into a movie in 1947.
the cast is as stacked as a deck of
tarot cards with rooney mara willem
dafoe david strathearn richard jenkins
and tony collette rounding out del
toro's world of colorful characters
and available to watch at home is
clifford the big red dog and the french
dispatch
this dog is killing me
who let the giant red dog out after 40
best-selling books three animated
television shows and a stage musical
there's finally a live-action adaptation
of clifford the big red dog norman
birdwell's beloved story of a tiny puppy
named clifford who grows to an enormous
size clifford affects the lives of
everyone around him and teaches a young
girl and her uncle the true meaning of
acceptance and unconditional love
darby camp plays the young girl jack
whitehall her uncle and a trove of
familiar comedians like john cleese tony
hale keenan thompson and david allen
greer round out the family hit after a
solid run around the block in theaters
paramount just announced a sequel to the
film plus fandango partnered with voodoo
to survey thousands of fandango users on
their favorite movies of 2021
nestled in voodoo's holiday sale which
starts today you'll find a list of fan
picks the best of 2021
from halloween kills to xiang chi and
the legend of the ten rings to dune and
the mitchells versus the machines you
can catch up on the most beloved 2021
movies of every genre on vudu alright
well that's it for today and
that's it for this year leave us a
comment and let us know what your
favorite movie of 2021 was i'm kale and
i'll see you next year
finally get to leave this chair i
haven't left this chair
all year
[Music]
you